I was spelling the word biosphere down the phone to people.
People didn't know what a bias fear is.
And so bias fear put not just the word
bias fear in our lexicon, but the concept,
the idea of what a bias fear is. And, you know, that's a,
that's a hugely important and transformative idea for humanity that we now
have, you know, the short form, our global biosphere.
I think we all basically have a general understanding of what that means now.
And you can really think buys for two for them.
[Inaudible].
Talk about isolation a lot on the show.
It seems like a once every third show. Yeah. We've talked about it.
And in relation to space like the international space station, Stanford,
tourists too, in a smaller respect and, uh, maybe even on other planets,
Mars space, colonization exoplanets as well.
We've also talked about it in relation to this planet,
because we've talked about living in isolation during a pandemic. Uh,
we talked about seasonal affective disorders that has it all sort of pertained
to that lockdown era that, you know, we're in now. And,
uh, you know, there's multiple ways to sort of imagine what that
scenario would be like. Yeah, well, unfortunately,
it's gone from imagining to us to real world scenarios said, yeah,
we know more than we've ever known about isolation,
but we still don't know what it would be like to live in a
closed bias sphere. You know,
who knows that there's some people there's very few people on this planet who
actually know the answer. Well,
how many have lived in a closed bias fear for two years,
eight people,
and one of them is joining us today and her name is Jane Poynter Jane. Perfect.
Welcome to what if discussed? Well.
Hello dad, gentlemen, it's.
Been a while, obviously since,
and you were such an integral part of obviously not just, you know,
participating in the biosphere two project,
but also being part of the design, uh,
leading up to it and really the legacy work after a lot
in terms of the, you know, where that science is being applied now.
But I guess the first place to start, I know it's a such a big question,
but what,
what was your experience in biosphere two?
So maybe it might be helpful before we talk about how I
experienced living in biosphere too,
just to sort of set the table a second and let everybody know what buys for two
ears was. Right.
So I was on the design team of this sounds very grandiose,
but it's true.
We were on the design team of humanity's first attempt to creating the
world's first human made biosphere, right?
So we all live in a biosphere that's biosphere, one be us,
and we were attempting to create biosphere to the first other
biosphere.
And so it was a three acre and still is it's still going today and is run by
university of Arizona. Uh,
it's a three acre enclosed environment that was completely sealed back in the
day. It was, was sealed when I was in there tight,
tighter than the international space station.
So there was essentially no air exchange without side.
And so all of the plants inside the rainforest, the Savannah, the ocean,
the mosh, the desert,
and the farm while creating all of our oxygen, you know,
we were creating some of the CO2 for all the ponds.
And so everything was recycling inside and we drank the same water over and over
again and read the same oxygen over and over again.
So one of the incredible things about being
inside biosphere two was that experience.
It was that experience of being viscerally part of my bias fear
and really understanding what it is to have a finite bias fear.
And for eight people buys two was pretty small, uh,
and it turns out that's very akin to the kind of experience that astronauts have
when they see the, from space. They see the auth from the outside in,
so they see the boundaries of this planetary biosphere that we all inhabit
and they too have a similar experience of Holy cow. ROS is not that big.
So I was, it was an amazing experience. It was also very hard because, you know,
as you were talking about in the intro being isolated is not necessarily the
easiest thing.
No, that's, and that's what I think we're talking about.
And you just mentioned with ASP astronauts,
I would think are the most isolated people, but after that,
this is a huge isolation, but, uh, to go into something like that, really,
you know, you really have to have a courage and,
and some sort of sense of an Explorer's curiosity. Obviously you had that.
Why do you think you were so willing to do this?
So it had nothing to do with being wailing. It was like I had to do it.
I was on the design team.
And so was I seriously going to let somebody else go in and test this out of
I had to go in and it was also the closest thing I ever thought I would get to
Mars. So for me,
this was almost like going in and testing a prototype space space as if we were
on Mars. And my favorite place to be was sitting on the beach that we had
looking out the incredible windows that were everywhere.
And we were in the Arizona desert, sunset,
the mountains around us turned red. And so for all the worlds we were on malls.
So I, for me, it was living out this extraordinary live stream of,
of going to mosque.
And it's interesting you say that because I think not everybody,
but a lot of people.
That, you know, I've talked to about this, you know,
they seem to remember or equate biosphere too, with, you know,
in an environmental ecological endeavor, which of course it was, again,
a lot of the science, a lot of the recycling, all those things, but in the end,
the impetus was what would it be like to live on another planet?
So that was really something that was, you know,
let's say ahead of its time, at the time,
over the course of the last X amount of years, Jane, you know,
you see movies like the Martian I could go on and on in the Spotify world,
how much and how, I don't know, what,
what's it been like for you to watch these people sort of apply some of those
things in pop culture and Saifai going forward as it relates to living on other
planets?
Well, I absolutely loved the Martian. Uh,
it was very true to life. I mean, as I was watching it, I was like, aha,
that's right. That's what I'm thinking.
People are watching that movie going well, that's absolutely accurate or that.
Well, you know,
and of course they also did a really good job of getting scientific input into
what he was writing. So that was also very cool and it was very apparent.
So I absolutely loved it. And it's thrilling. So look, I've been in,
in the human space flight world, my entire adult life.
Uh, and you know, I thought back in the day when we were advisory to,
we would be well on Mars by now. Uh, and at the time America,
I did have a plan to go to Mars, but, you know, as we know plans change.
So, uh,
what's been super exciting is to really see what's going on with commercial
space and, you know, that that's really taking off, uh,
in such a huge way. You know, it's sort of almost an overnight success.
That's been many decades in the making. Uh, so it's,
it's very exciting to see that, you know, and I think what's, uh,
what's super interesting and relevant about
space flight and human space flight is that it has this really unique
power to inspire, right?
There's really few other things that I think really capture the world in its
entirety and, and, and get people excited as spaceflight does.
You know, and, and I, we were talking a second ago about astronauts and,
and their experience of seeing us from space and one of the things that
I'm really drawn by as these sort of huge ideas.
And so the huge idea of being able to give,
being able to give as many people to see all from space,
it's incredibly important because, you know,
with all of these extraordinary global challenges that we have right here in
biosphere, one,
how important is it that we are based in a global perspective?
So I think this, uh, human space flight,
whether it's where to biosphere eventually, or, you know,
the kind of spacecraft that we see with the international space station is
really, really important.
There are a few years ago I interviewed, uh, the late great, uh, Edgar Mitchell,
six men to walk on the moon. Cool. He, you know, obviously, as you would think,
right, somebody who's an astronaut back in the day, well,
what what's their background usually are they're science people,
they're military people they're rigid. I don't want to say rigid,
but you know what I mean? There's structure not hippies.
Let's just say that right. Discipline. Well,
he comes back from having that experience and he,
I'm sure you're familiar with this Jane,
but he articulates what Jane's talking about.
It transformed him to see the like,
and I don't mean just like he I'm going to no,
he means he felt rewired from seeing the earth on its
own. I mean, other astronauts have talked about that,
but it actually changed the entire course of his life after that he started the
Institute for Noetic sciences and he, he talked about it almost like a,
almost like a religious experience, Jane.
Yeah. So actually that's very common. Uh,
and now we're beginning to see what I will loosely say of sort of
quantifying what happens to people who go to a space and have this
experience. And I think, uh, you know, I'm paraphrasing, but th there's the, um,
commentary that, you know,
we're going to space to explore space and instead we just gotta be us, uh,
and on what happens.
And now you can see it actually changes behavior.
Literally it changes people's behavior. You know,
like me going into bias for two, I was all about space. I'm going to Mars.
That's my only focus environment who cares. And, you know,
when I came out of the biosphere, I was like, Oh, wait a minute. Yes,
I'm the vice Varian too. We're all Biospherians of planet UF,
and we should care. And it's important. And what you'll see with, uh,
astronauts, when they go to space, it's very similar. They go up,
maybe they're involved in, you know, some social activities,
a little bit of environment when they come back,
it's just historically significant increase in the amount of interaction
they have with the communities on how involved they get with environmental and
social causes of, of many kinds.
It really is striking how it impacts us as a
human to get that place,
understand our place in our global biosphere.
So I guess all we need is to get everybody into space.
Hey, that's what I'm working on, but that's okay.
You were lucky enough to go and experience that.
So that's obviously your perspective.
There are many other perspectives on the success of biosphere too, but, uh,
like a lot of things with the benefit of time,
we see more and more the value of what we learned from biosphere two, uh,
as it helps guide other projects and science. And,
but what do you think is the most important legacy of biosphere two?
So of course there's,
there's many aspects of science
that, uh,
biosphere two has directly impacted and climate
science and bio J over, uh, cycling, uh,
all kinds of particular science about understanding how our planet works.
But when I really boil it down, you know,
one of the things that we have to remember is putting biosphere two
in its historical context.
So we were designing bias for two in the 1980s.
And I went inside in 1991, you know,
there was barely an internet. You know, people were hardly, you know,
you've got to really put yourself back there, right.
I was spelling the word biosphere down the phone to people.
People didn't know what a biosphere is.
And so bias fear put not just the word
bias fear in our lexicon, but the concept,
the idea of what a bias theory is. And, you know, that's a,
that's a hugely important and transformative idea for humanity that we now
have, you know, the short form, our global biosphere.
I think we all basically have a general understanding of what that means now.
And you can really think buys for two for that. Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely. And there's so much more, I mean, I'm,
I'm sort of boiling over here with questions because I'm really wanting to get
into the experience of being there, but also, you know, the social aspect of,
of eight people, all the other things, the oxygen issue.
Can you stick around Jane for a few more questions?
Sure. No problem. So, excellent.
We'll follow up with Jane on the audio version.
We'll continue to delve into all things biosphere with Jane Poynter and the
extended audio version of what if discussed if you're watching this on YouTube
right now, just click on the link below.
If you're already listening on the podcast. Well, just stay tuned.
And if you can't continue this journey with us well,
thanks as always for joining us on what if discussed.